good morning heck it's Tuesday but this
video isn't for you it's for your son
who recently asked why do things exist
which buddy is a really good question
and a really big one one of the strange
things about being a human is that big
questions occur to us even if they don't
seem to affect our day-to-day lives like
your question is about why the universe
exists and why there's so much stuff in
it and why some of that stuff happens to
be zinc and iron that we dig under the
surface of the Earth to pull out and
transform into 1987 U.S mail truck Hot
Wheels but regardless of why zinc exists
the Hot Wheel is still fun to play with
right and this is one of my very
favorite things about humans we don't
need to know why zinc exists in order
for Hot Wheels to be fun to play with or
for us to survive or whatever but we
still want to know and I think this urge
to know even if we don't necessarily
need to know in order to survive is kind
of the human superpower okay so let's
begin with us I'm not sure if this is
news to you but it continues to be weird
to me we are made out of the universe
even our thinking Parts like you may
hear that people and cats and the Earth
are mostly made of Stardust and that's
actually very true we are made out of
stuff that stars produced a very long
time ago as they burned but while
thinking about stars transforming into
humans and U.S mail truck Hot Wheels is
very interesting and important it tells
us more about how things exist and what
exists than why they exist like we know
that our planet which we call Earth is
rotating around a star which we call the
Sun and that star is just one of
billions in our Milky Way galaxy which
is itself just one of billions of
galaxies in the universe we also know
the universe like good five-year-olds
everywhere follows a set of rules that
shapes how it behaves and we know that
the universe is expanding that
everything is getting further away from
everything else at an accelerating rate
and we know that things are made out of
atoms which are themselves made out of
subatomic particles like protons and
electrons but why why why do things
exist hold on I have to go feed the
chickens by the way did you know that
after you make coffee there's this stuff
left over called coffee grounds that you
can use as garden fertilizer or as a
kind of like kitty litter for your
chicken coop it's true say hello to the
chickens greetings chickens it is I your
humble servant here to exchange food for
your eggs so coffee gives us energy and
then its remains give us happy chickens
and Gardens now I know what you're
thinking but where can I get amazing
coffee that's good for the people who
drink it and for the people who Farm it
and for the chickens
awesomecoffeeclub.com so why do things
exist we don't know we don't know why
things exist we are reasonably sure that
a little less than 14 billion years ago
everything currently in our universe was
in an unfathomably dense point of matter
and then exploded into being which we
call the big bang but we don't know why
and we don't even know why there is
stuff in the universe at all at least
according to our current models it is
just as likely maybe even more likely
that the same universe could be created
but without any matter in it so yeah we
don't know we don't know why there is as
much stuff in the universe as there is
instead of more or less stuff and we
don't know why the universe exists which
of course also means that we don't know
why we exist so that's weird but it's
also kind of exciting because that means
that the big questions may be the
biggest questions are still out there
waiting to be answered and you are one
of the people exploring those questions
which I think is awesome we are made out
of the universe we are not observers of
it we are participants in it and that's
why I think your question is so
beautiful because you my five-year-old
nephew are the universe trying to
understand itself
Oren I'll see your dad on Friday
PS Oren I'm pretty sure it's illegal to
Market directly to you but fortunately
you don't drink coffee
awesomecoffeeclub.com learn more about
our new coffee subscription there it's
great coffee that you can feel great
about